[Music]
a beautiful woman is heaven to the eye
held to the soul and Purgatory to the
pocket
it may be the [ __ ] that crows but it is
the hen that lays the eggs
women's instinct is often truer than
men's reasoning
[Music]
women are scientists by nature men by
books
[Music]
a man chases a woman until she catches
him
[Music]
women speak two languages one of which
is verbal
a pessimist is a man who thinks all
women are bad an optimist is a man who
hopes they are
there are three things men can do with
women love them suffer for them or turn
them into literature
a woman's whole life is a history of the
affections
the way to fight a woman is with your
hat grab it and run
the beauty of a lovely woman is like
music
[Music]
modern paintings are like women you'll
never enjoy them if you try to
understand them
foreign don't tell a woman she's pretty
tell her there's no other woman like her
and all roads will open to you
the beauty of a woman must be seen from
in her eyes because that is the doorway
to her heart the place where love
resides
[Music]
if you want something said ask a man
if you want something done ask a woman
women have discovered that they cannot
rely on men's chivalry to give them
Justice
[Music]
when black women win victories it is a
boost for virtually every segment of
society
[Music]
think like a queen a queen is not afraid
to fail
Ure is another stepping stone to
Greatness
[Music]
above all be the heroine of your life
not the victim
foreign
a woman who follows the crowd will
usually go no further than the crowd
the woman who walks alone is likely to
find herself in places no one has ever
been before
[Music]
there is a special place in hell for
women who do not help other women
well-behaved women seldom make history
[Music]
always be careful of what you hear about
a woman
rumors come from either a man who can't
have her or a woman who can't compete
with her
[Music]
feminism is the radical notion that
women are human beings
[Music]
a woman is like a tea bag you never know
how strong she is until she's in hot
water
[Music]
the age of a woman doesn't mean a thing
the best Tunes are played on the oldest
fiddles
[Music]
give a girl the right shoes and she can
conquer the world
a man's face is his autobiography A
woman's face is a work of fiction
dress shabbately and they remember the
dress
impeccably and they remember the woman
as a woman I have no country as a woman
I want no country as a woman I have the
whole world as my country
[Music]
the thing women have yet to learn is
nobody gives you power you must take it
[Music]
maybe some women aren't meant to be
tamed maybe they just need to run free
until they find someone just as wild to
run with them
[Music]
the most beautiful makeup of a woman is
passion
but Cosmetics are easier to buy
[Music]
the fastest way to change society is to
mobilize the women of the world
[Music]
when men are oppressed it's a tragedy
when women are oppressed it's a
tradition
you don't have to be anti-man to be
pro-woman
[Music]
little girls with dreams become women
with a vision
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
a man told me that for a woman I was
very opinionated
I said for a man you're kind of ignorant
[Music]
men are taught to apologize for their
weaknesses women for their strengths
[Music]
women are the largest untapped reservoir
of talent in the world
I measure the progress of a community by
the degree of progress which women have
achieved
[Music]
as usual there is a great woman behind
every idiot
women are the real architects of society
[Music]
the trouble with life is that there are
so many beautiful women and so little
time
foreign
men mourn for what they have lost women
for what they ain't got
women have this obsession with shoes
some women become the men they wanted to
marry
the hardest years in a woman's life are
those between 10 and 70.
if women didn't exist all the money in
the world would have no meaning
[Music]
the first time Adam had a chance he laid
the blame on a woman
like silent men they think they are
listening
being a woman is a terribly difficult
trade since it consists principally of
dealing with men
foreign
are fair
the trouble with some women is that they
get all excited about nothing and then
marry him
[Music]
wives are young men's Mistresses
companions for middle age and old men's
nurses
from love for a woman was born
everything beautiful on Earth
foreign
I don't know who invented high heels but
all women owe him a lot
when women go wrong men go right after
them
men are governed by lines of intellect
women by curves of emotion
almost all women seek to remake men and
when they succeed they lose interest in
them
a woman's guess has more accuracy than a
man's certainty
[Music]
whether women are better than men I
cannot say but I can say they are
certainly no worse
a woman should be like a single flower
not like a whole bouquet
a woman is a great educator of a man
[Music]
no matter how badly a man thinks of
women any woman thinks of them even
worse
[Music]
the more sexual partners a woman has had
the more likely she is to be depressed
[Music]
love the woman as you have made her or
make her as you love her
the woman becomes whole by becoming half
foreign
is like an echo how you treat her is how
she responds
God made women beautiful so that men
could love them and foolish so that they
could love men
[Music]
foreign